[Music]
you're sober birthday's coming up such a
whole milestone how does that feel it
feels amazing I all I've been doing is
focusing on bettering myself and it's
been quite the journey but it's well
worth overall when you think about the
most important thing that you did for
yourself to get to this place what is
that the most important thing that I did
for myself is surrender and surrendering
is the most important thing whenever
you're trying to battle your demons you
have to admit that you have a problem
first and then you can overcome also
want to ask you I think you're not
single right now are you while you're
you're seeing someone how's that going
it's going good
yeah what's going really good kind of
just lit up a little bit what's going
good about um I'm just having fun you
know and my life is in a really good
place right now and so yeah what about
him makes you smile um he makes me laugh
that's so important it's like more
important than anything good yeah
definitely what about what's in the
works for you and new music what can we
look forward to new music definitely I'm
in the studio right now every single day
and I was just listening to someone the
way over here I'm really excited for
everyone to hear we also want to ask you
I think it was joe said that he would do
an r-rated camp rock my idea my idea yes
and we're totally going to do it really
yeah real for real tell us the plot what
is it if you like American Pie meets
Disney Channel I love it if you guys for
real discusses yes we've really
discussed oh my god please meet can we
say it right now to ET it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen our rate of cambro our
rate again
you